David Boder: [Knocking sound] [In German] In dieser Richtung wird aufgezeigt, Sie brauchen nicht einfach da, aber Sie, eh, ge, eh, kommen Sie n bissel näher, eh, dort, nech, sagen Sie mal eins, zwei, drei . Hier.
Gert Silberbart: Eins, zwei, drei.
David Boder: Lauter?
David Boder: Ja, also, Sie passen aber mal langsam auf, wenn hier das Licht aufleucht-et—
David Boder: [In English] Geneva, August the 27th, 1946. A recording at the home for displaced boys, predominantly Buchenwald children, who are now being trained for a profession. The interviewee is Gert Silverberg [incorrect], eh, a native of Berlin.
David Boder: [In German] Also, Gert, sagen Sie uns nochmal, was ist Ihr voller Name, wie alt sind...?
Gert Silberbart: Gert Silberbart.
David Boder: Ja?
Gert Silberbart: Gert Silberbart und ich werde in dieser Woche 18 Jahre alt.
David Boder: Sie werden in dieser Woche 18 Jahre alt. Also erzählen Sie, Gert, wann hat es angefangen, Ihnen schlecht zu gehen? Denn da ist es ja auch vor dem Kriege schlecht gegangen.
Gert Silberbart: Ja, ja, selbstverständlich, aber bis zu dem Jahre 1938, bis zu der Erschießung dieses Rats in Frank—, in Frankreich haben wir noch nicht so viel von diesem ganzen Hitler-Regime gespürt, selbstverständlich etwas, aber—es war nicht soviel. Und als dann dieser Pogrom begann am 8. November, war ich, da wurden die ganzen jüdischen Geschäfte und Fabriken geschlossen, die Juden mussten die, ihre Judensterne tragen –
David Boder: Ja.
Gert Silberbart: . . . und das fiel natürlich sofort auf, und die Hitlerjugend und diese ganzen einfach Nazis, die machten sich das zunutze und [es] kam nicht selten vor, dass wir angepöbelt wurden auf der Straße.
David Boder: Also, sagen Sie nochmal, Gert, aus wem bestand ihre Familie, wieviel waren Sie in der Familie?
Gert Silberbart: Wir waren zuerst fünf, mein Bruder starb bereits aber vor dem Krieg an Diphterie, so dass nur noch vier übrig blieben, mein Vater, meine Mutter, meine kleinere Schwester und ich.
David Boder: Ja. Und, eh, sagen Sie mal, eh, was war Ihres Vaters Beschäftigung?
Gert Silberbart: Mein Vater hatte eine große Konfektionsfabrik, die er dann aber verkaufen musste—[TAPE NOISE]
David Boder: Also, eh, Sie sagen, die Schwierigkeiten haben angefangen, wie Rat bei Grünsp—, von Grünspan in Paris ermordet wurde, nicht wahr...
Gert Silberbart: Ja. Ja.
David Boder: Haben Sie ne Ahnung, was er [? 2.13] danach passiert?
Gert Silberbart: Davon haben wir keine Ahnung, als die ganze Geschichte verlautbar wurde, warn wir bereits im Konzentrationslager und hatten also keine Möglichkeit, irgenwelche Zeitungen zu lesen, ü—, und uns irgenwie orientieren, was draußen vorgeht.
David Boder: Ja. Also, eh, man hat, eh, Sie sagen, die Pogrome haben angefangen...
Gert Silberbart: Ja.
David Boder: Was für Pogrome waren sie, können Sie sie beschreiben, wenn Sie sich erinnern?
Gert Silberbart: Ja, ich kann Ihnen im Großen und Ganzen beschreiben...
David Boder: Doch be—, eh, beschreiben Sie sie im Kleinen, und im gu, eh, im Kleinen, nicht wahr
Gert Silberbart: Gut
David Boder: Also
Gert Silberbart: Die Geschäfte, die Schaufenster der jüdischen Geschäfte wurden in der selben Nacht und in den darauffolgenden Nächten noch—zersplittert, durch Steine, durch Steinwürfe und wurden oft Karikaturen an die Fenster gemalt, wurden in verschiedenen jüdischen Wohnungen eingebrochen und verschiedene Juden wurden auch angepöbelt auf der Straße.
David Boder: Ja. [knock] Nun? Sie waren ja bloß 10 Jahre alt, nicht wahr?
Gert Silberbart: Ich war damals 10 Jahre alt, ja.
David Boder: Und wie haben Sie— wie ist es Ihnen gegangen, und Ihrer Familie?
Gert Silberbart: Ja, kurze Zeit darauf wurden unsere Schulen für einige Zeit geschlossen...
David Boder: Welch—, was heißt unsere Schulen?
Gert Silberbart: Die jüdischen Schulen, die Schüler besuchten gemeinsam in Berlin...
David Boder: Also die—ja?
Gert Silberbart: Und wir durften uns gar nicht auf die Straße, weil sie nicht riskieren wollten, von den Banden der Hitlerjugend angepöbelt und geschlagen zu werden—und auch—fast kein Jude wagte es in den nächsten Tagen, über die Straße zu gehen.
David Boder: Ja. Nun?
Gert Silberbart: Das war eigentlich alles, was wir...
David Boder: Ja, und was hat mit Ihrem Vater, wegen, mit dem Geschäft Ihres Vaters passiert?
Gert Silberbart: Mein Vater musste sein Geschäft sofort verkaufen.
David Boder: Zu wem?
Gert Silberbart: An einen Arier, an einen Klienten.
David Boder: Ja. Hat er den, hat er Ihnen wenigstens bezahlt?
Gert Silberbart: Ja, selbstverständlich nicht den entsprechenden Betrag, den er bei, bei normalen Verhältnissen erzielt hätte, aber es wurde ihm einfach eine gewisse Summe ausbezahlt.
David Boder: Ja—und die konnte er zu sich nehmen oder musste er...
Gert Silberbart: Auch nicht, sondern man musste sie auf die Bank, auf, auf die Bank überweisen lassen und durfte dann immer nur einen ganz geringen Bret—, Betrag monatlich davon abheben.
David Boder: Ja, und dann, was hat der Familie passiert?
Gert Silberbart: Dann wurden wir alle nach Auschwitz, im Februar ’43, wurden wir alle nach Auschwitz deportiert.
David Boder: Wo ist Auschwitz, wo liegt das eigentlich?
Gert Silberbart: Auschwitz ist in Oberschlesien, das polnische Städtchen Ostepien. Also, dort wurde eben das größte Konzentrationslager kurz nach Einmarsch der Deutschen erbaut.
David Boder: Aha, also es war Polen bevor?
Gert Silberbart: Ja ja.
David Boder: Und dann, nach Einmarsch der Deitschen wu—, Deutschen, wurde dort ein Konzen-. -zentrationslager erbaut, nicht wahr...
Gert Silberbart: Ja.
David Boder: Nun, wie, wurde die ganze Familie nach Auschwitz geschickt?
Gert Silberbart: Ja, wir kamen, bis Auschwitz waren wir noch zusammen,
David Boder: Ja.
Gert Silberbart: . . . und wurden wir als, wurden wir getrennt. Meine Mutter, mein Vater und meine kleine Schwester [noise] wanderten, was ich annehme, sofort in die Gaskammer, während es mir, als Jüngstem, vergönnt war, da ich arbeiten, da ich arbeitsfähig war, unter den Lebenden zu bleiben.
David Boder: Also, warten Sie mal. Wo wur—, Sie wurden Sie in Berlin verhaftet. Wo wurden Sie dann, also von Ihrer Home, von Ihrem Haus aus bis Auschwitz gehen
Gert Silberbart: Ja.
David Boder: Wenn Sie gehen?
Gert Silberbart: Wir wurden von der Gestapo in der Nacht vom 7. zum 8. März 1943 in, aus unserer Wohnung verhaftet und kamen dann in ein Massenlager in, in Berlin direkt. Dort blieben wir bis zum...
David Boder: Wo war das Massenlager
Gert Silberbart: In Berlin, in der großen Hamburger Straße, es war eine frühere Schule, wo alle Möbel ausgeräumt wurden und einfach Matratzen in die Zimmer gelegt wurden.
David Boder: Ja, und ist die ganze Familie zusammen gewesen?
Gert Silberbart: Dort sind wir noch zusammen gewesen.
David Boder: Männer und Frauen und Kinder zusammen
Gert Silberbart: Ja
David Boder: Ja
Gert Silberbart: Ja, die ganzen Familien wurden noch nicht getrennt
David Boder: Ja. Nun? Dann?
Gert Silberbart: Dann am nächsten Morgen wurden wir, bekamen wir noch etwas zu essen, und wurden dann in Möbelwagen alle verstaut, und zum Bahnhof [noise] in der Nähe Berlins geführt.
David Boder: Also, nun sagen Sie mal, eh, was für Sachen haben Sie mitnehmen dürfen
Gert Silberbart: Wir haben zwar mitnehmen dürfen, was wir wollten, doch bei der Ankunft in Auschwitz wurde uns alles abgenommen, bis auf den...
David Boder: Ja, und was hat mit der Wohnung passiert
Gert Silberbart: Ja, wir wurden, und das, das weiß ich nicht mehr, ich weiß nur, dass die Gestapo-Beamten, nachdem wir die Wohnung verlassen hatten, ein Siegel der Gestapo aufgeklebt hatten, dass nunmehr keener eintreten durfte
David Boder: Ahe. Nun, und so sind Sie nach, eh—wieviel Tage ist der Zug nach Auschwitz gegangen?
Gert Silberbart: Drei Tage
David Boder: In was für einem Wagen sind Sie gefahren
Gert Silberbart: Im Viehwagen, zu achtzig Mann waren wir in einem Viehwagen, mit -.
David Boder: Die Familie zusammen?
Gert Silberbart: Ja, Frauen, Kinder, Männer, alle zusammen.
David Boder: Also, waren Sie mit Ihrem Bruder?
Gert Silberbart: Nein, mit meiner kleinen Schwester und mit meinen Eltern zusammen
David Boder: Mit Ihren Eltern zusammen.
Gert Silberbart: Ja
David Boder: Und eh, hat der Zug, ist der Zug stehenbleiben,
Gert Silberbart: Der Zug ist unterwegs oft stehen geblieben, jedoch haben wir davon weiter nichts gespürt. Als irgend etwas ist stehen geblieben, weil die Waggons wurden nicht geöffnet, erst als wir nach Auschwitz kamen, wurden sie—auch dort standen wir dann noch eine halbe Stunde, bis sie dann von den SS-Leuten mit den...
David Boder: Also wie haben Sie dann Ihre Toiletten besessen, mit, eh, eh...
Gert Silberbart: Na, da wurden so Eimer, Eimer in die Waggons gestellt, die wir dann durch ganz kleine Ritzen ausschütten, hinausschütten konnten, ins Freie...
David Boder: Ja. Und, eh, war da Trinkwasser...
Gert Silberbart: Es wurde uns ein Eimer zur Verfügung gestellt, der jedoch kaum ein Tag ausreichte.
David Boder: Und wie hat man das Wasser getrunken?
Gert Silberbart: Man hat es getrunken in Bechern oder Tassen oder irgend welchen Gefäßen, die jeder mithatte...
David Boder: Ja. Nun, und, eh, erzählen Sie mal, eh, wie, was hat passiert, die erste zwei Stunden, nachdem der Zug an Auschwitz angelangt hat.
Gert Silberbart: Wir wurden alle, wir wurden alle aus den Waggons entladen, und sofort eine laute Stimme rief sofort: Frauen, Männer, Frauen links und Männer rechts. Ich stellte mich dann zu den Männern, im Dunkeln hatte ich, wir kamen spat abends schon an und es war ziemlich im Dunklen noch, Anfang März, es war dunkel, ich hatte die Vater-Mutter Orientierung verloren, und kein, hab kein Mitglied meiner Familie mehr wieder gesehen.
David Boder: Also, Sie meinen , sie haben auch sofort Ihren Vater für sofort nicht mehr wieder gesehen
Gert Silberbart: Nein, ich habe kein Mitglied meiner Familie mehr gesehen
David Boder: Und Sie waren wie alt?
Gert Silberbart: Ich war damals 14 Jahre alt
David Boder: 14 Jahre, das war in welchem Jahr?
Gert Silberbart: Das war im Anfang ’43.
David Boder: Na, warten Sie mal—Sie sagen die Schwierigkeiten haben angefangen in ‘38
Gert Silberbart: Ja
David Boder: Wo waren Sie von ’38 bis ’43?
Gert Silberbart: Von ’38 bis ’43 befand ich mich noch in Berlin, ich besuchte bis zum Jahre ’41 die Schulen, die dann zwangsläufig geschlossen wurden.
David Boder: Ja. Und was hat Ihr Vater getan during dieser, durch diese Zeit?
Gert Silberbart: Mein Vater konnte während dieser Zeit überhaupt nicht arbeiten, und ist später zwangsläufig in eine Fabrik geschickt worden,
David Boder: Ja...
Gert Silberbart: . . . wo er dann arbeiten musste bis zu seiner Evakuierung.
David Boder: Also wenn er in der Fabrik arbeitete, ist er jeden Tag nach Hause gekommen?
Gert Silberbart: Ja.
David Boder: . . . da ist er jeden Tag nach Hause gekommen?
Gert Silberbart: Ja
David Boder: . . . also zwischen ’38 und ’42 haben Sie noch immer in Berlin gelebt, nicht wahr
Gert Silberbart: Ja.
David Boder: und Sie sind zur Schule gegangen bis ‘42
Gert Silberbart: Nein, bis zum Jahre ‘41
David Boder: Bis zum Jahre ‘41
Gert Silberbart: Ja.
David Boder: Und was haben Sie das für den Rest der Zeit getan, wo Sie nicht zur Schule gehen konnten?
Gert Silberbart: Da arbeitete ich in Küchen und auch in, eh, mein Freund, der Mischling war, sein Vater war Apotheker, der hat mich dann mit in sein Labor genommen...
David Boder: Ja.
Gert Silberbart: Wo ich mich dann ein wenig ausbilden konnte.
David Boder: War das, eh, erlaubt, nicht wahr?
Gert Silberbart: Das war nicht erlaubt, das war illegal, aber da es eben ein guter Freund von mir war, so kam das nicht an die Öffentlichkeit.
David Boder: Ja. Und dann haben Sie n bissel Apotheke gelernt, nicht wahr?
Gert Silberbart: Ja.
David Boder: Und, eh, dann, eh, wurden eh—sind die Leute gekommen und sie wurden ins Konzentrationslager nach Auschwitz geschickt in zweiund— in ’43...
Gert Silberbart: Ja, ja.
David Boder: Was, eh, haben die irgendwelche Gründe angegeben oder was war?
Gert Silberbart: Gar keine, wir warn ja noch ziemlich die letzten, wir hatten das Glück, unter den Letzten zu sein, und wir wussten schon, dass Tausende vor uns dorthin gewandert sind.
David Boder: Aha. Und dann sind Sie—wie alt war Ihre kleine Schwester?
Gert Silberbart: Meine kleine Schwester war damals acht Jahre alt.
David Boder: Aha. Und Sie waren, eh, 14 Jahre alt
Gert Silberbart: Ja
David Boder: Und Sie haben sich unter die Männer gemischt?
Gert Silberbart: Ja.
David Boder: Hat sich nicht Ihr, Ihr Vater mit den Männern hingestellt?
Gert Silberbart: Wahrscheinlich, ich hab ihn nicht mehr gesehen, wir wurden aufgerufen, jeder musste laut und deutlich seinen Beruf und sein Alter angeben, und, eh, auf einen Wink des SS-Oberkommandanten musste man sich dann eben rechts oder links aufstellen, rechts bedeutete die Gaskammern, links waren die Lebenden.
David Boder: Und was für einen Beruf haben Sie angegeben?
Gert Silberbart: Ich hatte gar keinen Beruf angegeben, einfach Schüler. Da ich aber damals ziemlich kräftig aussah, erschien ich ihnen eben arbeitsfähig und, eh, ich stellte mich zu den Lebenden.
David Boder: Ja. Und dann, was passierte nachher in wie [?]
Gert Silberbart: Dann wurden wir in eine Desinfektion geführt...
David Boder: War das in Birkenau oder in Auschwitz?
Gert Silberbart: Direkt in Auschwitz, wo wir ankamen.
David Boder: Ja—und wo waren die Krematorien?
Gert Silberbart: Die Krematorien waren in Birkenau, das ich jedoch zu dieser Zeit noch nicht gesehen hatte.
David Boder: Aha. Man konnte von Auschwitz Birkenau nicht sehen?
Gert Silberbart: Wir sahen ein großes Feuer, wir wussten aber nicht, was es bedeutete. Erst später wurde uns klar, dass es, dass das die Gasöfen, die Krematorien von Birkenau waren [noise]
David Boder: Aha. Aber man konnte von Auschwitz die Birkenau, eh, Feuer sehen?
Gert Silberbart: Ja, sehr gut.
David Boder: Ja. Nun? Und dann, was hat in der Nacht passiert?
Gert Silberbart: Wir wurden dann in ein Nebenlager von Auschwitz, das Arbeitslager Buna geführt...
David Boder: Ja.
Gert Silberbart: Wo wir alle entkleidet wurden, desinfiziert und alles abgenommen wurde, was wir auf dem Leibe hatten. Wir wurden gebadet, die Haare wurden uns abgeschnitten, und wir wurden in Häftlingskleidung gesteckt.
David Boder: Wer hat Ihnen die Haare abgeschnitten und wie wurde das getan?
Gert Silberbart: Schon la—, schon Häftlinge, die schon lange im Konzentrationslager waren, deren Beruf es eben war, als [?] zu funktionieren.
David Boder: Und was haben die gebraucht, Scheren oder, oder
Gert Silberbart: Einfache gewöhnliche Haarschneidemaschinen, mit der Hand zu bedienen.
David Boder: Was Hand?
Gert Silberbart: Mit der Hand zu bedienen, Haarschneidemaschinen.
David Boder: Also Handschneidemaschinen.
Gert Silberbart: Ja.
David Boder: Ja. Und man hat Ihnen das Haar vom Kopf abgeschnitten und?
Gert Silberbart: Ja überall, wo wir nur Haare hatten.
David Boder: Ja. Und dann, was hat man getan?
Gert Silberbart: Dann kamen wir in die einzelnen Baracken, man nahm unsere Namen und Personalien auf, unser Alter, steckte uns in die einzelnen Buchsen....
David Boder: Wie, was haben Sie als Ihr Alter angegeben?
Gert Silberbart: Mein richtiges Alter, 14 Jahre.
David Boder: Ja. Nun?
Gert Silberbart: Wir schliefen dann bis morgens um fünf, morgens um fünf bekamen wir erst ein wenig Kaffee, ein Stück Brot, und mussten uns dann vor den Block stellen, wo uns dieses Strammstehen und diese ganzen Schritte, dieser Marschschritt beigebracht wurden. Und dann...
David Boder: In welcher Weise?
Gert Silberbart: Verschieden. Wir mussten uns in Fünferreihen aufstellen, was noch ganz gut ging, dann wurde rechts und linksum geübt, dann marschieren, was zu Anfang nicht ganz so gut klappte, uns dann aber eben durch Kolbenschläge besser beigebracht wurde.
David Boder: Ja nun? Eh, essen Sie?
Gert Silberbart: Ja.
David Boder: Bisschen zu essen? [Pause]
David Boder: Also vor dem Essen sind wir ja dabei geblieben, wie Sie uns erzählt haben, dass man Ihnen beigebracht hat, wie zu marschieren. Nun gehen Sie mal weiter.
Gert Silberbart: Ja, und dann kam ein Mitglied des Arbeitsdienstes, dessen Aufgabe es war, unsere Berufe zu erfahren, und in welchem, in welcher Richtung wir eben arbeiten konnten.
David Boder: War das ein Häftling?
Gert Silberbart: Das war auch ein Häftling, der jedoch schon lange im Konzentrationslager war.
David Boder: Ja, war das ein Jude?
Gert Silberbart: . . . und das Vertrauen der SS-Führung hatte. Nein, das war kein Jude. Das war ein deutscher politischer Häftling.
David Boder: Ja. Ja.
Gert Silberbart: Und, da ich eben keinen Beruf hatte, wurde ich in ein Kommando gesteckt, in ein Arbeitskommando, wo ich den ganzen Tag Zement tragen musste und Waggons mit Eisen abladen musste, was mir natürlich mit 14 Jahren ziemlich schwerfiel, den ganzen Tag Säcke zu 50 Kilo zu schleppen, ohne Pause, ein Junge von 14 Jahren, ich meine, ich war das nicht gewohnt, es fiel mir ein wenig schwer.
David Boder: Ja.
Gert Silberbart: Aber dann gewöhnte ich mich dran, ich musste mich dran gewöhnen,
David Boder: Nun, und?
Gert Silberbart: Nun, und so arbeitete ich dann eben von sechs Uhr früh bis gegen sechs Uhr, sieben Uhr manchmal nachmittags, sechs oder sieben Tage in der Woche, es kam manchmal vor, dass wir sonntags Pause hatten, aber das hing dann nicht von uns ab, von unserer Arbeitsleistung, sondern eben von der, von den SS-Posten, die einfach sonntags nicht mit uns austreten wollten, uns bewachen, und selber im Lager bleiben wollten, oder außerhalb des Lagers in ihren Baracken waren.
David Boder: So was haben Sie dann am Sonntag getan?
Gert Silberbart: Am Sonntag hatten wir dann auch keine Ruhe, dann war Läusekontrolle, was uns zwar, was uns ziemlich unangenehm war, aber das war unserer Gesundheit zum Vorteil war, denn es waren viele unter uns, die sich schon nach kurzer Zeit Läuse geholt hatten, und die hätten uns sicher alle angesteckt, und wir, viele von uns wären dem Ungeziefer zum Opfer gefallen, wenn diese Läusekontrolle nicht gewesen ware.
David Boder: Also beschreiben Sie mal die Läusekontrolle.
Gert Silberbart: Ja, wir mussten uns halt alle nackend ausziehen und einer nach dem andern wurde vor den Arzt geführt, der dann eben uns gründlich untersuchte, ob wir Läuse hatten, einer nach dem andern.
David Boder: Ja, aber es waren nicht die Läuse in em Kleidern?
Gert Silberbart: Auch die Kleider wurden durchsucht.
David Boder: Nun, und wenn Sie Läuse hatten, dann was?
Gert Silberbart: Wir wurden sofort in eine Desinfektion geführt, vollkommen desinfiziert, untersucht, ob sie irgendwelche Anzeichen von Typhus aufweisen, wenn nicht, dann eben sofort wieder in den Block zurück gesteckt.
David Boder: Und wenn man alle, wenn man welche, eh, Zei—, Symptome von Typhus anzeigte, dann...?
Gert Silberbart: Dann blieben sie sofort im Krankenbau, wurden untersucht, und falls der Fall bereits so schlimm war, dass sie nicht im Lager geheilt wurden, werden konnte, dann kamen sie in das große Hauptlager von Auschwitz, wo der Krankenbau ein wenig besser ausgebildet war, und wo sie mehr Möglichkeiten hatten, den Patienten genauer zu unter—, zu untersuchen.
David Boder: Und? Wenn er Typhus hatte?
Gert Silberbart: Dann wurde er in eine spezielle Baracke gesteckt, bekam genau so zu essen wie alle anderen und wenn er eben geheilt wurde, wars gut, wurde er wieder zur Arbeit geschickt, wenn nicht, ja dann starb er eben.
David Boder: Ja. Nun? Also, eh, das war am Sonntag...
Gert Silberbart: Ja.
David Boder: . . . und wie lange hat das gedauert? Das war im ’43?
Gert Silberbart: Das war im Jahre ’43.
David Boder: Sommer, Winter?
Gert Silberbart: Anfang ’43, März, April, Mai.
David Boder: Ja.
Gert Silberbart: Dann wurde ich krank, hatte ’40 Fieber, ging sofort in den Krankenbau, in das K, in das KB, wie man das dort nannte, sie konnten aber...
David Boder: KB, Krankenbau
Gert Silberbart: KB, Krankenbau
David Boder: Ja?
Gert Silberbart: Sie konnten aber nicht feststellen, was ich hatte, mein Fieber hielt an und sie schickten mich mit einem Krankenwagen in das Hauptlager Auschwitz.
Gert Silberbart: Dort wurde ich in den großen Krankenbau geführt, man maß nochmal Fieber, ich hatte auch wieder etwas über ’40. Man ah— sah mir in den Hals, konnte aber wirklich nichts feststellen. Da stellten sie mich dann unter eine eiskalte Dusche, das mir ziemlich schwerfiel, darunter zu bleiben, ich musste aber, und diese Dusche wirkte dann einfach Wunder. Am nächsten Tag hatte ich bereits normale Temperaturen, man schickte mich sofort wieder in ein anderes Lager.
David Boder: Wie lange waren Sie unter der Dusche?
Gert Silberbart: Ich war unter der Dusche circa 15 Minuten.
David Boder: Wer hat das verordnet?
Gert Silberbart: Das ist, war gar keine Verordnung, jeder, jeder Patient, der von irgendeinem anderen Lager kam, wurde sofort desinfiziert und unter eine kalte Dusche gesteckt, und scheinbar hatten sie die Erfahrung, dass diese kalte Dusche massiv das Fieber runter gedrückt hatte und so machten sie sich das halt, dann eben zur Gewohnheit...
David Boder: Ja.
Gert Silberbart: . . . jeden Patienten unter eine Dusche zu stellen
David Boder: Und der Fieber war runter den nächsten Tag?
Gert Silberbart: Ja, ich war selbstverständlich stark geschwächt, aber das machte ihnen ja nichts aus hauptsache das Thermometer zeigte auf 36 und ich wurde sofort zur Arbeit geschickt.
David Boder: Ja. Nun, und dann was haben Sie dann wieder gearbeitet...
Gert Silberbart: Dort arbeitete...
David Boder: . . . und wie ist die Arbeit gegangen?
Gert Silberbart: Dort arbeitete ich auf ähnlichen Kommandos, auch als Maurergehilfe oder als Schlossergehilfe ganz wie man mich einteilte. Es war dort ein Teil—, teils Mangel auf diesem Kommando, an einem anderem Tag fehlten Leute auf jenem Kommando, so dass man uns von einem Tag auf dem anderen in die verschiedensten Kommandos steckte.
David Boder: Ja, nun?
Gert Silberbart: Dort blieb ich dann bis Ende ’44. Bis zur...
David Boder: Und wie ist es während der Arbeit gegangen, war die Behandlung mehr oder weniger gut?
Gert Silberbart: Die Behandlung...wir wurden selbstverständlich stark geschlagen aber das ist eben...
David Boder: Warum ist das so selbstverständlich?
Gert Silberbart: Das ist selbstverständlich, glaub ich...Ich glaube, dass das eben von Büchern und Vorträgen und Filmen genug bekannt ist, dass ich das gar nicht mehr erwähnen brauch. Denn die Schläge waren einfach etwas, was so, was zum Konzentrationslager gehört genauso wie in einem Büro eine Schreibmaschine gehört.
David Boder: Wer haben Sie meistens geschlagen?
Gert Silberbart: Die Kapos sowie auch die SS-Männer.
David Boder: Wie, wer waren die Kapos? Beschreiben Sie die bitte.
Gert Silberbart: Die Kapos, das waren Häftlinge, die schon seit Jahren im KZ saßen, die die SS genauer kannte, und die dann eben von der SS oder vom Arbeitsdienst, von dem Arbeitsdienst der SS eine gelbe Binde mit der Aufschrift Kapo bekamen und die dann einfach für die Verant—, für die Arbeitsleistung des Tages verantwortlich waren.
David Boder: Was ist der, eh, die Herkunft des Wortes Kapo? Warum haben die Deutschen das gebraucht?
Gert Silberbart: Das weiß kein Mensch. Das ist bis heut noch nicht bekannt.
David Boder: Kapos ist im Lateinischen Kopf oder Führer oder...
Gert Silberbart: Es kann sein, dass es daher kommt.
David Boder: Sagen Sie, haben Sie das Wort Muselmann gehört?
Gert Silberbart: Selbstverständlich, als Muselmänner wurden die bezeichnet, die da eben durch, durch schwere Arbeit stark abgemagert, stark abgemagert waren und geschwächt und bei dem, diesen Muselmänner, das waren die, das einfach nach Beendigung der Arbeit alle durchs Tor ins Lager einmarschieren mussten, sich ausziehen und sich vor dem Lagerarzt einer nach dem andern kamen. Dieser Lagerarzt entschied dann auch wieder durch ein Wink seiner Hand rechts oder links, links die wanderten in den Gasofen rechts sie blieben weiter bei ihrer Arbeit.
David Boder: Ja, was heißt das, sie wanderten in den Gasofen?
Gert Silberbart: Sie wurden alle sofort gesammelt von der SS,
Gert Silberbart: . . . selbstverständlich gab es großes Geschrei, denn die Leute wussten alle, wohin sie kamen. Es war einem...Es war nicht das erste Mal, dass solche Situationen vorkamen. Sie kamen dort auf einen Block, alle zusammen unter starker SS-Bewachung, und dann meistens am darauf folgenden Tag sofort in Wagen verladen nach Birkenau und in die Gaskammern.
David Boder: Sie sagen, es war großes Geschrei.
Gert Silberbart: Selbstverständlich haben die Menschen geschrien und gebetet. Ich mein’, ein Mensch, der weiß, dass er in zwei Stunden, drei Stunden vergast wird, der ist nicht mehr menschlich, der ist verzweifelt, nicht?
David Boder: Nun, hat das Bitten mal geholfen?
Gert Silberbart: Sicher hat das nicht geholfen. Da—, davon, das wussten die Leute auch, aber in dem Moment, wo man soweit ist, da vermag man einfach nicht mehr, logisch zu denken, da ist man nicht mehr der Herr seiner selbst.
David Boder: Haben Sie das selbst gesehen und gehört?
Gert Silberbart: Ich habe es selbst gesehen und gehört.
David Boder: Wie kam es, dass Sie durchgekommen sind?
Gert Silberbart: Ich war eben...Ich war eben einfach noch stark genug, um arbeiten zu können.
David Boder: Aha. Nun, also, wie lange hat das gedauert in Auschwitz?
Gert Silberbart: Dort lebte ich bis Ende ’44, bis gegen September.
David Boder: Ja.
Gert Silberbart: Eines Tages kam dann eine Kommision eines deutschen Werkes, Siemens...von dem Sie schon gehört haben,
David Boder: Siemens und Halske oder?
Gert Silberbart: Siemens Schuckert.
David Boder: Siemens und Schuckert, ja.
Gert Silberbart: Und einen Tag, bevor diese Kommission kam, hieß es im Lager, alle Jugendlichen sollten im Lager bleiben.
David Boder: Ja.
Gert Silberbart: So blieben wir dann im Lager. Diese Kommission kam. Wir wurden dieser Kommission vorgestellt, und sie prüften uns einige Fragen, auf unsere Schulbildung hin prüften sie uns und sie sagten uns, dass sie Schlosserlehrlinge brauchten.
David Boder: Also, das waren nicht mehr die Kapos oder SS.
Gert Silberbart: Nein, das waren Zivilisten.
David Boder: Zivilisten. Waren die höflich?
Gert Silberbart: Sie waren sehr höflich zu uns. Sie schlugen einen ganz, gänzlich ungewohnten Ton an.
David Boder: Ja.
Gert Silberbart: Was wir niemals vorher gewohnt waren, weder von den SS-Leuten noch von den Kapos.
David Boder: Ja. Und sie haben mit Ihnen freundlich gesprochen, oder?
Gert Silberbart: Sie haben mit uns ziemlich freundlich gesprochen.
David Boder: Ja.
Gert Silberbart: Sie haben uns Verschiedenes gefragt,
Gert Silberbart: . . . betreffs unserer Herkunft unserer Schulbildung,
David Boder: Ja.
Gert Silberbart: . . . stellten uns verschiedene Fragen und schieden dann 25 von uns aus, die dann eben in ihrem Betrieb als Schlosserlehrlinge eintreten sollten.
David Boder: Und Sie waren darunter.
Gert Silberbart: Und ich war darunter.
David Boder: Ja.
Gert Silberbart: Von diesem Tag an brauchten wir dann eben nicht mehr zur Arbeit zu gehen, kamen auf einen Quarantäne-Block, wo wir circa acht Tage blieben und wurden dann in einem Auto abgeholt, auch von SS-Männern, und kamen in ein kleines Lager, das gerad gegründet wurde, in der Nähe von Auschwitz.
Gert Silberbart: Dort wurden wir auch wieder desinfiziert, wieder neu eingekleidet, Haare wurden uns geschnitten, die schon...
David Boder: . . . wie früher...
Gert Silberbart: . . . wie früher, und wir begannen dann unsere Arbeit, zuerst die Maurerarbeiten, denn die Fabrik war noch nicht gänzlich hergestellt, dort hatten wir noch Auß—, Außenarbeiten zu leisten, bis dann die Fabrik endlich hergestellt worden war, Maschinen wurden hinein gestellt und wir begannen langsam mit dieser Schlosserarbeit.
David Boder: Ja.
Gert Silberbart: Zuerst wies man uns noch einige Sachen an, später aber brauchten sie uns doch zu den Außenarbeiten, mehr wieder zum Mauern, zum Sandschippen und so weiter, so dass wir kaum einen Unterschied merkten zwischen Auschwitz und diesem kleineren Lager. Wenigstens, dass wir ein bischen mehr Ruhe hatten, wir waren im Ganzen 150 Häftlinge, nur, außer dem Kommando nur, da waren da nur noch einige SS-Posten da, so dass wir es als ziemlich angenehm empfanden, unter so wenig Menschen zu sein.
David Boder: Hat die, war die Behandlung besser?
Gert Silberbart: Die Behandlung war ein wenig besser, einfach deshalb schon, weil ein einziger Kommandoführer nicht an allen Stellen sein konnten, wo wir eben dieses, diese Zeit, wo er am, an der anderen Ecke des Lagers war, ausnutzten, um uns ein wenig auszuruhen.
David Boder: Und waren da keine Kapos?
Gert Silberbart: Es war ein Kapo, der aber ziemlich nett war, weil er auch nicht so viel Angst haben brauchte vor dem Kommandoführer, denn schließlich machten es die Kapos in Auschwitz auch nur aus Angst, denn sie wurden schließlich gerügt, wenn die Arbeitsleistung nicht genügend war,
David Boder: Ja.
Gert Silberbart: Selbstverständlich hatten auch sie es versucht, sich bei den SS-Leuten berühmt zu machen, sie bekamen Zigaretten, so dass es ihnen so darauf nicht ankam, ein Schlag mehr oder weniger.
David Boder: Ja. Nun, und so haben Sie bei Siemens und Schuckert gearbeitet?
Gert Silberbart: Ja.
David Boder: Wie lange hat das gedauert?
Gert Silberbart: Dort habe ich gearbeitet bis Ende des Jahres ’44, Anfang ’45, bis zum Januar. Als dann die Russen langsam im Osten vorrückten, wurde die Lage bedenklich, und wir marschierten von, von diesem Lager, Bobrek [?] hieß es, bis nach Buna [?], wo ich früher gewesen war, ganz zu Anfang...
David Boder: Buna?
Gert Silberbart: Ja.
David Boder: Es war Bobrek, das Außenlager?
Gert Silberbart: Das, das Lager war Bobrek.
David Boder: Ja.
Gert Silberbart: Dann kam ich in das Lager Buna zurück, wo ich ganz am Anfang ’43 eingeliefert wurde. Dort blieben wir circa drei Stunden, das ganze Bu—, Lager Buna wurde evakuiert, und wir marschierten von Buna nach Buchenwald direkt.
David Boder: Wie weit war das und wie lang hat der, eh, Marsch gedauert?
Gert Silberbart: Ich kann, ich kann Ihnen nicht die geringste Entfernung angeben, ich weiß es wirklich nicht,
David Boder: Also Buna ist bei Auschwitz?
Gert Silberbart: Buna ist bei Auschwitz, einen Kilometer von Auschwitz entfernt.
David Boder: Also...
Gert Silberbart: Buchenwald ist bei Thüringen.
David Boder: Und, eh, also Buna ist, Auschwitz ist neben Breslau ungefähr .
Gert Silberbart: Nein, nein, Auschwitz ist viel. viel weiter als Breslau, Breslau ist bereits das deutsche Oberschlesien,
David Boder: Ja...
Gert Silberbart: . . . während Auschwitz Polen ist.
David Boder: Ja, also Auschwitz, und da, is, ging es nach Thüringen, nicht wahr?
Gert Silberbart: Dann ging es nach Thüringen
David Boder: Ja, nun?
Gert Silberbart: Wir liefen zuerst von Buna circa 50 Kilometer, bis wir an eine Scheune kamen in Nikolau [?], wo wir das erste Mal Rast machten, einige Stunden.
David Boder: Was heißt, Sie liefen?
Gert Silberbart: Wir, wir marschierten
David Boder: Ja
Gert Silberbart: Ununterbrochen, 50 Kilometer
David Boder: Kilometer
Gert Silberbart: . . . was uns natürlich sehr schwer fiel in unseren Holz-[?]Schuhen, in unserer dünnen Bekleidung und durch den Schnee, und die SS-Männer trieben uns an.
David Boder: War es nicht zu schnell für die SS-Männer auch, zu gehen?
Gert Silberbart: Es sind verhältnismäßig viel SS-Männer dabei oft schwach geworden und haben nicht mit durchhalten können.
David Boder: Und was hat denen passiert?
Gert Silberbart: Die wurden dann auf ein Krankenauto geladen und kamen, wurden heil ins Lazarett gebracht.
David Boder: Ja. Und, eh, was wurde mit den Häftlingen getan, die nicht mitkonnten?
Gert Silberbart: Die Häftlinge, die nicht mitkonnten, die liefen einfach aus der Reihe und bekamen den Gnadenschuss und blieben liegen und wurden dann später von einem Auto, das alle Leichen aufsammelte, mit aufgelesen und ins Krematorium gebracht.
David Boder: Einen Gnadenschuss? Nun?
Gert Silberbart: Ja, man kann das Gnadenschuss nennen.
David Boder: Und?
Gert Silberbart: Ja, und dann, nachdem wir diese erste Pause hinter uns hatten, die circa acht Stunden dauerte in Nikolai, marschierten wir weiter bis nach Gleiwitz. In Gleiwitz war auch so ein Konzentrationslager gewesen, das inzwischen aber schon geräumt worden war, dort blieben wir eine Nacht.
David Boder: Langsamer, bisschen langsamer, ja? Ja?
Gert Silberbart: Natürlich, das Lager war zu klein gewesen, um die ganzen Häftlinge von Buna und Bobrek in sich aufzunehmen...
David Boder: Wieviel Mann, denken Sie, waren das ungefähr?
Gert Silberbart: Es waren circa 40—, 45.000 Mann, jedoch weiß ich nicht, ob meine Schätzung richtig ist, ich hab wirklich keine Ahnung.
David Boder: Nu ja—ja?
Gert Silberbart: Auf dem Weg waren auch schon Hunderte liegen geblieben...
David Boder: Nun?
Gert Silberbart: Jedenfalls ein Teil des La—, ein Teil...
David Boder: No, wenn solche Leichen liegen geblieben sind, hat man denen die Kleider angelassen oder haben andere...
Gert Silberbart: Man hat sie ihnen angelassen, da man einfach keine Zeit hatte, jeden ihm wegzunehmen, da so wie man sie, diese Leute, die da liegen geblieben waren, die waren aus der Reihe, und jeder, der aus der Reihe lief, wurde sofort erschossen, wegen Fluchtversuch. Folglich hatte keiner die Gelegenheit, aus der Reihe zu laufen und den, die Toten ihrer Kleider zu berauben.
David Boder: Ja.
Gert Silberbart: In diesem Lager Gleiwitz blieben wir nun über Nacht, und am darauf folgenden Tag. Viele schliefen nachts lieber draußen, da im Lager nicht genug Platz war für uns alle.
David Boder: Wie war das mit der Verpflegung?
Gert Silberbart: Verpflegung bekamen wir dort kurz vor unserer Abfahrt nach Buchenwald, ein kleines Stück Brot und ein—circa 50 Gramm Wurst.
David Boder: Ja.
Gert Silberbart: Wir wurden also am Abend des darauf folgenden Tages in Waggons aufgeladen, wir, es waren manche Waggons bis zu 150 und 200 Mann voll.
David Boder: Konnte man etwas essen?
Gert Silberbart: Einer wur-—Man, man konnte sie essen, wir fragten in einer solchen, bei einer solchen Gelegenheit schon nicht mehr, was zu essen war und was nicht zu essen war, wir essen manches, wo wir heute, wo wir heute einen Ekel empfinden würden.
David Boder: Zum Beispiel?
Gert Silberbart: Ja, einfach, was wir au—, was wir aus den Müllkästen auf der Straße aufgelesen hatten. Kartoffeln, Mohrrüben, verfaulte, und so weiter, Rüben.
David Boder: Ja, während dem, während dem, dem Gang. Nun sagen Sie, wenn man so marschierte, wo sind, ist man nicht Städte durch gegangen, durch Dörfer?
Gert Silberbart: Wir sind meistens durch das Land marschiert. Wir, nur einige Bauern sahen uns. Natürlich,wir kamen so, passierten auch kleinere Städte und auch Dörfer. Die Bevölkerung schaute uns nur zu, aber bei dem Anblick der SS verging ihnen sofort alles und sie verzogen sich in ihre Häuser.
David Boder: Ja, und Sie haben keine Gelegenheit, mit den Leuten zu reden?
Gert Silberbart: Nee, nie.
David Boder: Also, weiter.
Gert Silberbart: Und so waren wir dann eben in die Waggons aufgeladen, der Zug setzte sich in Bewegung, es war in der ersten Zeit furchtbar. Wir hatten keine Gelegenheit, zu sitzen in den Waggons, furchtbar, wir waren 150 Mann, einer stand an den andern gepfercht.
David Boder: Geschlossene Waggons?
Gert Silberbart: Offene Waggons. Oben offen.
David Boder: Oh, das waren die offenen Waggons?
Gert Silberbart: Ja.
David Boder: . . . und das war im Winter?
Gert Silberbart: Das war im Winter.
David Boder: Ja, nun.
Gert Silberbart: Wir hatten unsere dünne Kleidung und von Stunde zu Stunde, kann man beinah sagen, starben welche.
David Boder: Wovon?
Gert Silberbart: Durch die kal—, durch Kälte, teils durch Hunger, teils durch Schwäche, eins hing ja schließlich mit dem andern zusammen. Die Toten wurden dann aus dem Waggon geworfen. Erhielten noch teils, manche noch einen Schuss, manche nicht mehr und dadurch wurde uns immer mehr in den Waggons Platz. Es ist tatsächlich schlimm, wie man das jetzt sagen muss, aber wir empfanden es einfach gar nicht mehr als schlimm, wenn jemand starb, wir waren damals so...so herunter, dass einfach der Selbsterhaltungstrieb war in dieser Situation über jeden einen Herr geworden, und, wir machten uns eigentlich kaum noch Kopfschmerzen über das Los der andern.
David Boder: Waren das bloß Männer oder Frau—, oder Frauen?
Gert Silberbart: Es waren nur Männer.
David Boder: Ja, nun. Und so?
Gert Silberbart: Und so, so blieben wir dann, von unserm 150 Mann starken Waggon kamen in Buchenwald nur 80 Mann an. In Buchenwald wurden wir vollkommen entkräftet ausgeladen, manche konnten schon nicht mehr laufen und liefen dann ins Lager.
David Boder: Ja...
David Boder: Was zirka 1 Kilometer von der Rampe entfernt war.
David Boder: Von dem Zug.
Gert Silberbart: Ja.
David Boder: Ja nun?
Gert Silberbart: Dort wurden wir dann auch...kamen wir zuerst, wir kamen nachts um 12 an, dann kamen wir in eine, in einen Block, zu 2000 Mann in einen Block. Aber wir waren toden—, wir waren totmüde und ganz entkräftet. Wir schliefen ein, einfach dort, wo man uns hinlegte oder wo wir standen. Am nächsten Morgen kamen wir in die Desinfektion, wir waren fast alle verlaust...
David Boder: Ja...
Gert Silberbart: . . . und wir bekamen neue Kleider, die Haare wurden uns geschoren und wir kamen in das sogenannte Kleine Lager, das war ein, das bestand aus zirka zehn Blocks, die früher als Pferdebarracken dienten, wo zirka 2000 Mann drin Platz hatten nach dem Rauvermögen der Deutschen natürlich...
Gert Silberbart: . . . und dort blieben wir zirka, dort blieb ich zirka einen Monat, zwei, anderhalb Monate blieb ich dort. Dort hatten wir eigentlich den ganzen Tag ziemlich wenig, wir bekamen auch überhaupt nichts zum Essen und das ist diese Stunden,...die Zeit ist uns so langsam herumgeschlichen...Das war tatsächlich furchtbar.
David Boder: Haben Sie nicht gearbeitet?
Gert Silberbart: Wir haben, ja, wir wurden manchmal zum Steinbruch als Aushilfe aber wir waren, wir waren gar nicht fähig zu arbeiten. Ein kleiner Stein von drei, vier Kilo konnten wir nicht mehr heben.
David Boder: Ja.
Gert Silberbart: Wir waren durch die ganze Fahrt in diesen letzten Wochen so entkräftet gewesen, wir wären einfach nicht fähig gewesen, zu arbeiten.
David Boder: Nun?
Gert Silberbart: Diese Zeit, wo wir nicht Arbeit hatten, hat uns auch nicht kräftiger gemacht, im Gegenteil, noch schwächer, denn man schickte uns während des ganzen Tages in die Kälte hinaus, wir hatten nur einen ganz dünnen Anzug, der ungefähr einem heutigen Pyjama gleicht, ein Paar Holzschuhe, Strümpfe hatten wir keine und so blieben wir den ganzen lieben Tag in einem kleinen abgezäunten Raum vor dem Block stehen. Wir froren, viele hatten Frostbeulen. Frost an den Fingern, zu denen sich manchmal, zu denen manchmal eine Infektion, ein Abzess zukam und viele starben daran.
David Boder: Nun? War das ein, eh, Jugendlicher-Block?
Gert Silberbart: Nein das war kein Jugendlicher-Block, das waren alle durcheinander.
David Boder: Nun?
Gert Silberbart: Ja, und dann nach zirka anderthalb Monaten kam ich dann in das...kam ich in das große Lager...
Gert Silberbart: . . . dort reihte man mich dann ein Ko—, in ein Kommando, das in der Stadt Weimar, das, die sieben Kilometer zirka von Buchenwald entfernt liegt, Aufräumungsarbeiten zu verrichten. Dort in Buchenwald war es, was die Arbeit anbetrifft, viel schlimmer, wir mussten schon manchmal um drei Uhr oder um vier Uhr früh auf dem Apellplatz stehen und arbeiteten manchmal bis sieben, acht Uhr abends, bis neun Uhr abends sogar manchmal, in der Stadt.
David Boder: Ja, in welcher Stadt, in Weimar?
Gert Silberbart: In der Stadt Weimar, ja.
David Boder: Ja. Was hat man dort gearbeitet?
Gert Silberbart: Die zerstörten Häuser, die durch Sturmangriffe und die durch Lufttorpedos zerstört worden waren, den Schutt wegräumen und eben helfen, sie wieder aufzurichten.
David Boder: Wie hat das ausgesehen? War das sehr zerbombt, Weimar?
Gert Silberbart: Weimar war ziemlich start zerstört.
David Boder: Und, eh, haben Sie auch unter dem Schu—, Schutt Lei—, Leichen gefunden?
Gert Silberbart: Leichen haben wir ziemlich selten gefunden. Wir hatten...suchten unter dem Schutt nach Lebensmitteln, wovon wir jedoch oft ziemlich wenig fanden.
David Boder: Sie fanden wenig. Haben Sie manchmal wertvolle Sachen gefunden?
Gert Silberbart: Nie.
David Boder: Nun weiter. Konnte man was mitnehmen, was man gefunden hatte?
Gert Silberbart: Nein, man wurde bei der Kontrolle beim Eintritt ins Lager geprüft, prüften uns nach dem Einsatz bis auf die, bis auf die Knochen durchsucht, so dass nichts ins Lager mit hinein gebracht werden konnte.
David Boder: Nun.
Gert Silberbart: Dort arbeitete ich so bis gegen, bis März ‘43
David Boder: Ja...
Gert Silberbart: . . . bis März ’45 wollte ich sagen. Und dann rückten die Amerikaner langsam näher. In der letzten Zeit, als die Amerikaner schon in Erfurt waren...
Gert Silberbart: . . . da rückten wir nicht mehr aus, denn die Gefahr war so groß. Der Lager-Kommandant, ein SS-Obersturmführer, hatte schon vorher gesagt, wir brauchten keine Angst haben, wir sollten keinen Aufruhr machen. Er würde uns in alle Ruhe den Amerikanern übergeben.
David Boder: Das hat der Lager-Kommandant gesagt.
Gert Silberbart: Das hat der Lager-Kommandant gesagt. Wir, wir glaubten natürlich nicht daran.
David Boder: Und glauben Sie, er hat die Wahrheit gesagt?
Gert Silberbart: Er hat selbstverständlich nicht die Wahrheit gesagt, dass haben wir, haben wir schon daran gesehen, dass einige Tage später hieß es: Alle Juden antreten.
David Boder: Ja.
Gert Silberbart: Selbstverständlich versammelte sich, war kein Jude auf dem Apellplatz zu sehen, so dass am nächsten, so dass sich die SS am nächsten Morgen dazu gezwungen sah, selber ins Lager einzurücken um die Juden mit Kolbenschlägen auf den Apellplatz zu jagen. Von dort aus wurden sie sofort aus dem, aus dem Lager hinaus transportiert. Unter SS-Bewachung traten sie den Marsch an.
David Boder: Waren Sie darunter?
Gert Silberbart: Nein, ich war nicht darunter. Wenn ich darunter gewesen wäre...
David Boder: Wieso [nicht]?
Gert Silberbart: Weil ich, ich hatte mich in verschiedenen Blocks versteckt, in Kellern, teils in Kana—, in Löchern der Kanalisation, auf Böden, kurz in allen Schlupfwinkeln, wo ich nur irgendwie untertauchen konnte.
David Boder: In Löchern der Kanalisation?
Gert Silberbart: Ja,...in der Kanalisation.
David Boder: Waren sie nicht verschmutzt dort?
Gert Silberbart: Selbstverständlich waren sie verschmutzt, aber ich wusste, we rich, wenn ich aus dem Lager heraus kam, den Marsch antreten musste, das war mein Tod.
David Boder: Wieso haben Sie das gewusst?
Gert Silberbart: Weil ich einfach nicht mehr fähig war, 2-3 Kilometer zu laufen, ich war das durch die ganzen letzten Wochen und Monate so entkräftet, ich konnte kaum auf den Beinen stehen.
David Boder: Aha, nun?
Gert Silberbart: So hielt ich mich versteckt zirka eine Woche. Dauernd hieß es, Juden raus, Juden raus und als dann die größte Teil der Juden hinaus war, ging es auf die Christen über. Täglich gingen Transporte aus dem Lager, so dass im Lager, das vor einer Woche noch 100.000 Menschen beherbergt hatte, bei der Befreiung am elften April durch die Amerikaner nur 22.000 Menschen übrig geblieben waren.
David Boder: Ja, also, wer waren die andere, die man genommen hat?
Gert Silberbart: Ein—, die SS nahm einfach alle, die man, die sie aufschnappen konnte. Zum Schluss gab es...
David Boder: Nun ja, konnten Sie nicht alle aufschnappen? Es waren ja...die Blocks waren ja offen.
Gert Silberbart: Ja, sie konnten, sie konnten eben nicht alle auf—, aufschnappen, weil sich einfach ein großer Teil verborgen hatte, im Lager. Dann war es ihnen einfach zu viel, sie hatten nicht so viel Posten, so viel SS-Männer, die uns bewachen konnten, alle auf den Weg zu schicken.
David Boder: Ja, nun?
Gert Silberbart: Ja, und dann...
David Boder: Sind was, welche Leute, die auf dem Weg waren, weggelaufen?
Gert Silberbart: Nein, das war, ist keinem gelungen.
David Boder: Nun? Und so?
Gert Silberbart: Und so kamen dann eben am 11., eben am 11. April gegen 4 Uhr nachmittags, kamen die Amerikaner und befreiten uns.
David Boder: Na, und wie war das? Wollen Sie das, die letzten drei Tage ungefähr, die— uns erzählen.
Gert Silberbart: Die letzten drei Tagen vor der Befreiung soll ich Ihnen erzählen?
David Boder: Ja. Ja.
Gert Silberbart: Gut, also, ich befand mich während diesen, während dieser ganzen letzten drei Tage in Kellern und Kanalisationslöchern, habe während dieser Tage nichts gegessen, nichts getrunken, immer nur gehört, immer nur ängstlich auf den Schrei gehorcht, wann es heißt Juden raus, und wenn sich einer, wenn irgendetwas in meiner Nähe gerührt hatte, wenn ich irgend ein Geräusch hörte, schreckte ich sofort ängstlich zusammen.
David Boder: So sagen Sie, drei Tage wirklich nichts gegessen?
Gert Silberbart: Ja. Es war nicht, es war nicht das erste Mal. Ich hatte schon sieben Tage gehungert. Nichts gegessen und nichts getrunken.
David Boder: Na ja. Wo, wann haben Sie sieben Tage gehungert, nichts gegessen, nichts getrunken?
Gert Silberbart: In der ersten Zeit in Buchenwald.
David Boder: Wieso, hat man nichts zu essen gegeben?
Gert Silberbart: Nein, wir hatten nichts zu essen bekommen.
David Boder: Aber Wasser war ja.
Gert Silberbart: Wasser war.
David Boder: So haben Sie doch getrunken.
Gert Silberbart: Gut. Wenn man das als Wass— als, Latrinenwasser als ein Getränk...bezeichnen möchte...
David Boder: Warum war das Latrinenwasser...war da nicht, eh, reines Wasser...
Gert Silberbart: Nein, an das reine Wasser konnten wir nicht, an das reine Wasser konnten wir nicht kommen.
David Boder: Und was ist das, was meinen Sie, Latrinenwasser...haben Sie in der Latrine eine Wasserspülung gehabt?
Gert Silberbart: Es war einfach schmutziges Wasser, rostiges Wasser, verschmutztes Wasser, das aus irgend einem Rohr floss, das war dann...
David Boder: Und das hat man getrunken.
Gert Silberbart: Das tranken wir.
David Boder: Nun.
Gert Silberbart: Ja, nun...
David Boder: Aus welchen...Was für einen Sinn war es, nicht Ihnen zu erlauben, sich Wasser zu holen...
Gert Silberbart: Darüber kann ich Ihnen keine Auskunft geben. Da hätten Sie bei den Leuten erkundigen sollen, die es, die es uns verboten hatten...
David Boder: Ich meine...Haben Sie nicht was gesagt?
Gert Silberbart: Wir haben nichts gesagt. Wir nahmen es beinahe als etwas Selbstverständliches hin. Wir waren schon an solche Sachen gewöhnt, an solche Schikanen.
David Boder: Aha. Nun, und so?
Gert Silberbart: Und so hatte ich, so verlebte ich die letzten drei Tage in Kanalisationslöchern und...
David Boder: Ja
Gert Silberbart: Und Böden und Kellern undsoweiter...
David Boder: Nun?
Gert Silberbart: Bis ich dann, am 11. April gegen Nachmittag, einen Jubelschrei hörte und aus den Radios die amerikanische Musik und dann sofort hervorkroch, ganz erschöpft und dann fielen wir uns weinend in die Arme...
David Boder: So amerikanische Musik von den Radios...?
Gert Silberbart: Es ist so gewesen. Im Zimmer des Lagerkommandanten, das außerhalb des Lagers war, war ein große...ein Mikrofon...
David Boder: Ja...
Gert Silberbart: . . . in jedem Block im Lager...
David Boder: . . . ein Lautsprecher.
Gert Silberbart: . . . ein Lautsprecher.
David Boder: Nun?
Gert Silberbart: . . . und in dieses Radio, das beim Lagerkommandanten im Zimmer war, da—, daraus ertönte amerikanische Musik. Sofort standen Häftlinge...
David Boder: Wieso waren, eh...
Gert Silberbart: Er hatte ein einfaches Radio dabei. Er, er hat während dieser ganzen Zeit sicher diese amerikanische Musik gehört...
David Boder: Aha...
Gert Silberbart: . . . aber sie wurde eben durch den Lautsprecher nicht, nicht übertragen...
David Boder: Nicht, nicht kanalisiert...
Gert Silberbart: Ja.
David Boder: . . . so haben sie die einfach eingetönt, die amerikanische Station?
Gert Silberbart: Ja...
David Boder: Eingestimmt und man hat amerikanische Musik eingestimmt?
Gert Silberbart: . . . Hat sofort amerikanische Musik gehört. Nun dann die ersten Amerikaner liefen dann sofort Reden durch den Lautsprecher. Wir wurden...einfach, dass wir frei waren.
David Boder: Nun.
Gert Silberbart: Wir konnten das einfach in den ersten Stunden gar nicht fassen. Ja, und dann fielen wir uns weinend um den Hals und—es ist eigentlich kaum zu schildern, die letzten, die ersten Stunden nach der Befreiung
David Boder: Probier mal!
Gert Silberbart: Ja, als ich dann hervorkroch, sah ich einige Kameraden wieder, die ich schon langem kannte, wir fielen uns um den Hals und konnten es fast nicht fassen, dass wir frei waren, waren dann aber so erschöpft von den letzten Tagen, die wir nichts gegessen hatten, kurz wir waren ganz erschöpft. Das Schlimme war noch, dass die Deutschen in ihrem Rückzug die ganze Wasserleitung zerstört hatten, so dass im ganzen Lager kein Wasser war und wir beinahe verdursteten.
David Boder: [In English] This concludes Spool, this concludes Spool 82 reported by Gert eh, by Gert Silbert...eh, Silbert, is that the name?
Gert Silberbart: Silberbart...
David Boder: Silberbart und we are going over to Spool 83. Geneva, August the 27th, 1946. Illinois Institute of Technology recording.
David Boder: [In German] Sie hörten amerikanische Musik...also ein Moment...
David Boder: [In English] This is Spool 83, a continuation of 84, eh...82, Gert Silberbart concluding his report.
David Boder: [In German] Also, Sie sagten, Sie hörten amerikanische Musik...nun?
Gert Silberbart: Ja, und dann krochen wir eben alle aus unseren Schlupfwinkeln hervor, freuten uns unserer wieder erhaltenen Freiheit, viele brachen bei diesem Eindruck, bei dieser Begebenheit zusammen...
David Boder: Haben Sie auch paar Amerikaner sofort gesehen?
Gert Silberbart: Ja, wir sahen sofort amerikanische Panzer, die die Stacheldrähte, die elektrischen, sofort durchfuhren. Sofort sah man auf allen Dächern weiße Fahnen, kurz und gut, das ganze Lager brach in ein Jubeln und Lachen aus.
David Boder: Wer hat die weißen Fahnen errichtet?
Gert Silberbart: Das waren einfache Bettlaken...
David Boder: Ja, aber wer? Die, eh, haben Sie...
Gert Silberbart: Häftlinge, von uns, nein, nein, ja...
David Boder: Nun, die Häftlinge haben sich ja nicht ergeben zu brauchen. Die weißen Fahnen meinten was?
Gert Silberbart: Nein, die weißen Fahnen meinten einfach, dass wir mit den Amerikanern zusammen sind, dass wir...
David Boder: Ja...
Gert Silberbart: . . . dass sie nicht etwa ihre Waffen gebr—, schießen sollten oder was...
David Boder: Ja, was ist mit den Kapos passiert?
Gert Silberbart: Die Kapos sind, ein Teil der Kapos, die ein unreines Gewissen hatten, die während dieser ganzen Zeit mit den SS-Männern kollaboriert hatten, sind mit den SS-Männern geflohen, die in den letzten Minuten noch geflohen sind.
David Boder: Die Juden...waren sie? Juden-Kapos?
Gert Silberbart: Ich glaube, in Buchenwald gab es keine Judenkapos, kann man echt sagen.
David Boder: Aha, ja. Nun?
Gert Silberbart: Einfach diese eh, diese deutschen Kapos, Schwerverbrecher, Berufsverbrecher, so was...
David Boder: Die sind mit den SS-Männern geflohen. Nun...
Gert Silberbart: Die Kapos, die tatsächlich ein reines Gewissen hatten, die sich gegen ihren, gegenüber ihren Mithäftlinge gut benommen hatten, die blieben mit uns und feierten auch ihre Freiheit.
David Boder: Ja. Nun. Eh—hat man welche SS gefangen? Hat man...
Gert Silberbart: Man hat sehr viele gefangen noch auf dem Weg, denn...viele Häftlinge nahmen, eh...räuberten, holten sofort diese Waffenmagazine, diese Arsenale der SS aus...
David Boder: Ja...
Gert Silberbart: . . . und bewaffneten sich und die, die kräftig genug waren, liefen die SS hinterher zusammen mit den Amerikanern. Es wurden ziemlich viel noch gefangen genommen.
David Boder: Und was hat man mit denen getan?
Gert Silberbart: Die hat man zuerst ins Lager gebracht...in einen Block zusammengehalten. Sie wurden entwaffnet und alles abgenommen. Sie wurden dann einige Tage später von den Amerikanern von der Militär weiter nach Deutschland hinein transportiert.
David Boder: Hatten Sie die Gelegenheit gehabt mit den SS zu reden?
Gert Silberbart: Ich selber hatte keine Gelegenheit, denn ich war die ganze Zeit viel zu schwach um auch nureinige Schritte hinauszugehen.
David Boder: Nun.
Gert Silberbart: Ich musste mich wieder stärken.
David Boder: Aber haben andere es getan?
Gert Silberbart: Ja, ich habe mich einfach nur ausgeruht. Andere hatten Gelegenheit mit den SS-Leuten zu sprechen. Viele nahmen auch Rache an Ihnen.
David Boder: In welcher Form?
Gert Silberbart: In einfacher Form, in dem sie sie schikanierten.
David Boder: Ja. Haben die Amerikaner die in irgend welcher Weise die SS verteidigt oder beschützt?
Gert Silberbart: Weder verteidigt noch beschützt. Sie nahmen, in der ersten, in den ersten Tagen sah man ziemlich wenig Amerikaner in unserem Lager, denn das Lager war noch Frontgebiet, diese ganze Gegend. Erst später, als sich die Front weiter nach Deutschland hineinverzogen hatte, kam ein spezieller Lagerkommandos von der amerikanischen Armee, ein große Nummer von Personal, einfach diese, mit der Ordnung des Lagers zu beschäftigen hatten, und auch viele Tankwagen der amerikanischen Armee kamen, die einfach Wasser ins Lager brachten. Denn es sicher eineinhalb Wochen nach der...nach unserer Befreiung war die Wasserleitung wieder in Gang gesetzt.
David Boder: Aha. Nun sagen Sie, eh, da waren ja so viele Häftlinge, wie kam es, dass man überhaupt die SS am Leben gelassen hat?
Gert Silberbart: Man hat sie am Leben gelassen. Denn wenn wir sie nicht hätten am Leben gelassen, dann wären wir, wären wir ja gar nicht viel anders gewesen als die Deutschen. So, wir mussten, wir wollten ja doch schließlich mit gutem Beispiel vorangehen, wenn nicht mit gutem Beispiel, aber wir sollten doch nicht so handeln, wie sie an uns gehandelt haben, dann wären wir ja schließlich die selben.
David Boder: Das war die Philosophie von der Sache?
Gert Silberbart: Das war nicht die Philosophie von der Sache. Das ist meine Ansicht. Sicher haben viele eine andere Ansicht vertreten. Im Großen und Ganzen war es aber die Ansicht des Lagers.
David Boder: Ist es wahr, dass die Häftlinge welche SS gehängt haben in Buchenwald?
Gert Silberbart: Dass die Häftlinge SS-Leute gehängt haben?
David Boder: Ja?
Gert Silberbart: Das kam zweimal vor, soviel ich weiß.
David Boder: Ja. Wann?
Gert Silberbart: Das waren dann—nach der Befreiung.
David Boder: Ja?
Gert Silberbart: Das waren tatsächlich SS-Leute, die sich einfach unheimlich schlimm gegen Häftlinge benommen hatten. Aber davon hatte ich nur gehört, so dass ich genauere Einzelheiten darüber nicht berichten kann.
David Boder: Das haben Sie selber nicht gesehen?
Gert Silberbart: Nein.
David Boder: Nein. Nun, und wie ging es dann mit dem Essen und mit der Verpflegung?
Gert Silberbart: Das Essen verbesserte sich sofort natürlich in einem unheimlich starkem Maße. Viele die an diese gute Kost des amerikanischen Militärs nicht gewohnt waren, und das war ja keiner...
David Boder: Ja...
Gert Silberbart: . . . bekamen sofort Durchfall, Magen...Magengeschwüre, Magenkrämpfe. Und es bekam fast keinem gut. Das ganze Lager hatte Durchfall. Und erst später langsam, langsam gewöhnten wir uns wieder an die normale Kost.
David Boder: Nun? Und wie lange waren Sie dann in Buchenwald?
Gert Silberbart: Dann war ich in Buchenwald noch bis zum, bis Anfang Juni des Jahres 1945, als dann viele Jugendliche sich durch die UN [?] einschreiben lassen mussten und die Transporte nach der Schweiz gingen und darunter war ich auch. Und so bin ich dann in die Schweiz hierher gekommen.
David Boder: Sie haben die Schweiz gewählt?
Gert Silberbart: Ja.
David Boder: Haben Sie probiert, Ihre Familie, jemand aufzufinden?
Gert Silberbart: Ich habe bereits genug Recherchen gemacht. Ich habe aber überhaupt keine Hoffnung mehr, dass irgend jemand von ihnen Leben gelieben ist. Ich hab’ nur meine Tante und meinen Onkel in Chile wieder gefunden, die schon währ—...die schon vor dem Kriege dorthin emigriert waren.
David Boder: Wie heißen die?
Gert Silberbart: Dahlinger.
David Boder: Dahlinger. Und wie haben Sie sie gefunden? Haben Sie denen geschrieben, haben Sie geantwortet?
Gert Silberbart: Ich habe durchs Rote Kreuz und verschiedene Organizationen Recherchen gemacht und eine ist dann einfach, eine Nachricht ist von ihnen gekommen. Und im September vorigen Jahres hatte ich die erste Nachricht von ihnen.
David Boder: Aha. Und eh, was tun Sie jetzt?
Gert Silberbart: Jetzt im Moment lerne ich Zahntechniker in einem Laboratorium der OSE und besuche nebenbei einen Abendkurs der Handelsschule und lerne Englisch, Französisch und...
David Boder: Welche Handelsschule?
Gert Silberbart: Hier in Bern das Institut Commercial.
David Boder: Das ist eine private Schule?
Gert Silberbart: Nein, das ist eine staatliche Schule.
David Boder: Und Sie dürfen diese Schule be-?
Gert Silberbart: Ich durfte diese Schule besuchen, die OSE, die auch das, den Zahntechnikerkurs finanziert, hat mir erlaubt, diesen Kurs zu besuchen und finanziert den auch.
David Boder: . . . und finanziert diesen Kurs. Und wie vertragen Sie sich dort mit Ihren Mitschülern?
Gert Silberbart: Ich, ich hatte, ich bin noch nicht lange in diesem Kurs, erst einige Tage, da der, das Wintersemester jetzt angefangen hat...
David Boder: Ja...
Gert Silberbart: . . . hab’ noch eigentlich, noch gar keinen näheren Kontakt mit meinen Mitschülern, aber es geht gut.
David Boder: Aha. Wussten Sie, dass Sie, eh, ein früherer Häftling waren?
Gert Silberbart: Ich glaube. Ich weiß es nicht. Sie haben mir jedenfalls nichts gesagt.
David Boder: Und Sie sind jetzt wie alt?
Gert Silberbart: Ich werde jetzt 18.
David Boder: Und was sind Ihre Pla—, Pläne? Was wollen Sie in der Zukunft tun?
Gert Silberbart: Ich beabsichtige nach Absolvierung dieses Zahntechnikerkurses und dieser Kurs der Handelsschule zu meinen Verwandten nach Chile zu gehen und dann weiter dort als Zahntechniker zu arbeiten.
David Boder: Wollen Sie nicht dann Zahnarzt studieren?
Gert Silberbart: Zahnarzt studieren, ich glaub’ dazu werde ich keine Möglichkeit haben, denn dazu ist die Maturität erforderlich. Ich bin bereits zu alt und...
David Boder: . . . zu alt...
Gert Silberbart: Nicht zu alt, aber ich habe einfach nicht mehr genug Zeit, um mich darauf vorzubereiten.
David Boder: Nu ja, Sie sind ja bloß eine einzelne Person. Sie könnten ja vielleicht was verdienen und für die Maturität arbeiten, nicht wahr.
Gert Silberbart: Ich hatte nie in der Schweiz eine Gelegenheit, etwas zu verdienen, ich wüsste nicht als was.
David Boder: Aha. Nun, Gert, das war eine, ein sehr ausführlicher Bericht. Ich habe von Ihnen Manches gehört, das ich von anderen nicht gehört habe, denn ich habe sehr wenige deutsche Häftlinge gehabt. Sie haben auch sehr intelligente Sachen beschrieben. Ich bin überzeugt, dass es ein guter Report ist und vielleicht werde ich auch in Chicago gewissen deutschen Gruppen mal diesen [Rat] vorspielen lassen. Ich bin überzeugt sie werden...ich kann nicht sagen, freuen, aber sie werden zufrieden sein, etwas davon zu lernen. Danke sehr.
Gert Silberbart: Bitte sehr...
David Boder: [In English] This concludes the report with Gert Silberbart at, eh, about seven minutes of Spool 83. Paris, August the 27th, 1946. In a home supported by the Swiss government for refugees of the war. Illinois Institute of Technology wire recording.
David Boder: This concludes the reproduction of Spool 9-83, the interviewee was Silberbart. The sign-off gave by mistake Paris, it really was in Geneva but somehow the interviewer automatically having interviewed people for a number of days in Paris still gave the sign-off as Paris. It is Geneva...Switzerland. November the 14th, 1950, Chicago, of course. Boder.